oh
[Musique]
non
mais
il
[Musique]
oui
oh
bonsoir monsieur boni dans mon choix
votre nouvelle émission ça consiste en
quoi
spectacularité la culture faire
découvrir aux téléspectateurs des
personnages historiques ou des
personnages de fiction ça va de
cléopâtre à madame bovary en passant par
lennon et lénine et chapelles comment
hôtel du temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
princesse diana bonsoir mesdames pas
princesse des liens
que vous dicter votre coeur avant que
vous ne rencontrions le prince charles
et puis le grand jour arrive
[Musique]
et
je n'ai pas au mauvais caractère j'ai du
caractère c'est tout alors forcément tu
comprends quand on a du caractère il est
toujours mauvais pour les autres à ce
qu'on fait parce qu'ils veulent un
jour princesse
[Applaudissements]
moi la femme libre à qui personne ne
dictait sa loi un même pas eu de la gt
aux petits soins pour toi
[Musique]
on
des corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux